[Music]
someone once told me that I had three
strikes against me I'm african-american
I'm female and I'm a lesbian in this
culinary world we are a group of people
that are underrepresented and I chose to
not let those three strikes be my out
[Music]
BMW proudly supports the LGBTQ community
[Music]
twisted soul cookhouse is my baby it is
a dream come true so what makes twister
so different from the other restaurants
in Atlanta is me this is my story so
before I started cooking professionally
I was a flight attendant for 33 years
you know and I found myself on lay overs
you know my favorite tourist activity
was grocery shopping I loved working in
first class and then just adding my own
little nuances and touches to the
first-class meal at a point I decided I
had to be true to myself you know and
it's just open a restaurant and
start cooking every day doing something
I wanted to do I run twisted soul with
my wife and also my daughter we are that
family that works together in place
together when I first decided I was
interested in women I was very quiet
about it I was afraid of how it would
affect my business and then I realized
one day that I was doing myself an
injustice once I became comfortable with
who I was in my talent I became
unstoppable what I do with global
comfort food and for me that is soul
food I think all cultures have a soul
I felt like soul food was a food that
was underrepresented and was presented
as being unhealthy not pretty and I
decided I wanted to do something about
it by infusing it with other cultures I
have a little bit of Jamaican influence
there's Asian influence
there's African influence I am telling
the story of my life when people come to
the restaurant you know I want them to
experience what it's like to be in my
home I love you know to see their faces
and you know watch them close their eyes
and just salivate over what I've created
since Whiston soul is open we've been
featured on major networks we've been
featured in multiple publications we get
guests from all over the world
and we're looking at opening restaurant
number two the soul of food for me is
what comes from within being
african-american being female being less
man on a white male dominated industry
has not stopped me from being myself
passion does not have a gender passion
does not have a color and my passion has
taken me far
[Music]